la serbie devait participer ce mois ci
aux exercices militaires fraternité
clave 2020 mais le ministre serbe de la
défense alexander vu line a annoncé
renoncer à y participer
on nous a demandé au prix d'un abandon
de notre avenir européen de renoncer aux
exercices militaires prévus avec la
biélorussie la serbie qui est neutre sur
le plan militaire a été confrontée à une
forte pression non méritée de la part de
l'union européenne et suspendra en
conséquence sa participation aux
exercices militaires avec tous ses
partenaires pendant six mois une
décision qui n'affectera pas la relation
qui lie la serbie à la russie comme l'a
expliqué le porte parole du kremlin
on ne peut que constater le fait que la
serbie a suspendu tous les exercices
militaires pour les six prochains mois
ce n'est pas à cause de la russie ou
d'un autre pays nous respectons cette
décision des autorités serbes
en août dernier la serbie a été
complimenté par des ambassadeurs
occidentaux après avoir apporté son
soutien à une déclaration de l'union
européenne critiquant l'élection
présidentielle controversée en
biélorussie depuis le 2 mars 2012 la
serbie est reconnu comme candidat
officiel pour l'union européenne
le pays a entamé les négociations en
janvier 2014 en 2018 la commission
européenne a indiqué que l'adhésion de
la serbie ne se ferait pas avant 2025
sept pays sont actuellement candidat
pour rentrer dans l'union européenne
l'albanie la macédoine du nord le
monténégro le kosovo la turquie la
bosnie herzégovine et la serbie